“Help me!
Would somebody please help me?
I’m lost and I can’t see!”
It echoed through the alley in a thin, reedy
voice that suggested brittleness of body and
spirit.
Who wouldn’t hear that cry and feel a pang
of sympathy?
Are you so heartless that you’d ignore the
desperate pleas for help of a blind man, clearly
in distress?
For all you know, he might even be in danger.
What if he walks into a road and gets hit
by a car?
Would you really want that on your conscience?
Questions like these were flying through the
head of the Good Samaritan when he decided
to go and investigate, when it seemed like
everyone else was just content to pretend
they didn’t hear it and carry on with their
day as normal.
The Good Samaritan was a person not unlike
yourself.
They were also the kind of person we all hoped
and wished we would be in a situation such
as this.
Kindness and generosity is a virtue, after
all.
The problem is, there are people out there
who know this, and are willing to take advantage
of that kindness and generosity.
But even worse is the fact that there are
things that are definitely not people out
there willing to take
advantage of human compassion,
too.
But back to the Good Samaritan.
He approached the sound of the distressed
man in the alley: He looked old and frail,
hunched over with the weight of his years.
He wore thick, dark glasses, and his white
cane was laying on the road a few feet away
from him.
It was a tragic scene, but thankfully, the
Good Samaritan was here to help.
He approached the old man, calmly telling
him that it was okay.
The Good Samaritan picked up the walking cane
and passed it over to the blind old man.
His face spread into a warm smile, and he
said.
“Thank you, thank you, thank you, young
man.
It warms my heart to know there are still
good people like you on this earth.”
The old man told the Good Samaritan that he’d
come into town to get some fresh air and a
little exercise, at which point he’d gotten
lost.
When the Good Samaritan asked whether it was
safe for him to come alone, the old man told
him that he always used to go on walks with
his wife, but ever since the accident, she
didn’t seem to want to be seen in public.
The Good Samaritan naturally felt for the
old man, who seemed as sweet as he was feeble.
He offered to escort the old man back to his
house personally, wanting to make sure that
he returned home safely.
The old man smiled and graciously accepted,
saying that his wife would probably want to
thank the kind young man for helping him in
person.
Of course, the Good Samaritan was so wrapped
up in the warm glow of doing a good deed that
he never once stopped to question the strangeness
of this whole situation.
He just walked along with the old man, listening
to him tell his fanciful stories, as they
left the city center and crept further into
the sleepy outskirts of their small Kentucky
town.
He was just rambling on, as old men tend to.
He told the Good Samaritan a little more about
his beloved wife: She was a kind woman whom
he’d known for as long as he could remember.
His elementary school sweetheart, then his
high school girlfriend, and not long after
they graduated, his beautiful, blushing bride.
Oh yes, she’d always been the prettiest
lady, until the accident.
Curiosity was getting the better of him: The
Good Samaritan couldn’t help but ask what
exactly the “accident” he kept alluding
to was, and the old man was all too happy
to give him an answer.
Not that this answer was, in any way, pleasant.
His wife had been trapped in a terrible fire
in town that gave her severe burns all over
her body.
She was lucky to be alive, but the flames
took her beauty and her confidence away from
her.
Since then, she’d become a real homebody,
often refusing to leave the house, and rarely
ever letting strangers see her.
The Good Samaritan’s heart ached for this
poor old couple.
Why were such nice people often forced to
endure so much suffering?
Did this old man even have anyone else to
talk to?
They reached his house soon enough, it was
the furthest one on the end of the street,
right next to the darkness of the woods.
It looked old and dilapidated, but it wasn’t
like the old blind man could even know that.
As they were walking up the small set of stairs
to the porch, the old man stumbled slightly,
causing his thick, dark glasses to fall to
the floor.
The Good Samaritan reflexively leaned over
to pick up the glasses for the old man, and
as he passed them back, he noticed something
strange.
The old man wasn’t just blind, he literally
didn’t have any eyes.
Just two black, empty sockets where his eyes
should be.
The Good Samaritan was just thankful that
the old man wasn’t able to see him staring
as he put the glasses back on.
The two of them entered the house.
The Good Samaritan was too busy thinking about
the old man’s empty eye sockets to even
notice him locking the door behind them, and
by then, it was already too late for him.
The old man called out into the dark expanse
of the house.
“Sweetheart, I’ve got you a live one!”
Before the Good Samaritan could ask what he
actually meant by that, the old man shuffled
off, deftly navigating the halls through memory
alone, and took one of the two seats at the
dining table.
He just sat there, smiling.
Waiting.
That’s when the Good Samaritan heard a creaking
sound coming from above.
Something moving, up in the darkness of the
second floor, and then descending the stairs
with heavy, clomping footsteps.
When his eyes came into focus in the dark,
he saw it there, the most terrifying thing
he’d ever witnessed, coming down the stairs
towards him.
It was vaguely human in its shape alone, but
in all other respects, it was a monster through
and through.
This gnarled, twisted creature with bulging
eyes, dead flesh, and filthy exposed fangs.
Like it’d stepped straight out of a nightmare
and into the physical world, where it did
not belong.
There looked to be a huge hole in its lower
torso, too, with no blood or organs inside.
Just an infinite blackness.
The creature’s lipless mouth twisted into
a smile.
The creature said something in a voice that
the Good Samaritan couldn’t understand.
It was the Black Tongue, something ancient,
terrifying, and unknown.
As the creature got closer and closer, the
Good Samaritan turned and made a run for the
door.
He tried to figure out the lock, his hands
fumbling and uncoordinated by fear.
He could hear the footsteps and the heavy
breathing of that thing getting closer behind
him.
He was so close...Almost there...
That’s when a strange, black substance seemed
to encase the world around him.
It separated him from the door he was so nearly
able to breach, locking him in.
He was trapped inside what looked like a giant,
black sphere made of some unknown material
or energy.
He turned to see that monster standing right
behind him, just grinning and waiting for
the inevitability of the situation to sink
in.
The Good Samaritan had never been more terrified.
Something else began to shift inside the sphere.
A structure was growing out of the ground,
up and around him, like a cage within a cage.
He was trapped and huddled inside a strange
conical structure, as more figures entered
the sphere around him.
They were just like the first, this horrible
horde of desiccated not-people.
All with grinning, lipless mouths.
When they closed in on him, the Good Samaritan
had the one consolation that at least it was
over.
But it wasn’t.
Not yet.
The blind old man waited in the kitchen for
five hours as unmentionable horrors unfolded
inside the black sphere.
The Good Samaritan was actually lucky, all
in all, because some sessions for victims
inside the sphere had lasted as long as 27
hours.
He screamed the entire time, with the sphere
finally de-manifesting just moments after
the screaming stopped.
Remaining, was only one of the creatures,
but no Good Samaritan.
Just several neat piles of human organs, arranged
by organ type.
“Are you done in there, honey?” the blind
old man asked.
“I’ve been getting awfully hungry.”
The creature replied, in perfect English.
“Yes, dear.
I’ll fix you up some supper before you go
to bed.”
The creature picked up some of the discarded
organs and took them into the kitchen, where
it began cooking them into a stew for the
old man.
He ate the stew not long after, blissfully
ignorant to its contents, and went to sleep.
Whatever organs from the Good Samaritan weren’t
used in the stew were simply thrown into the
fireplace to burn away into ashes.
Later that night, the old man would die peacefully
of a heart attack in his sleep at age 81.
He spent the latter ten years of his life
in service of SCP-957.
He’d never even had a wife, and when the
monster first invaded his home, he wasn’t
even blind.
He’d simply come home one day to find SCP-957
lurking in his home, waiting for him.
As far as the SCP Foundation is aware, it
always targets people who live alone.
The man had tried to resist, but the creature
was freakishly strong in spite of its wiry
frame.
It grabbed him and forced his body into the
dark, gaping chasm of its chest.
He was swallowed up into another world on
the other side of the void, and returned four
hours later, a changed man.
His eyes were gone, and he now firmly believed
that SCP-957 was his beloved, if burn-scarred,
wife of many years.
He’d do anything for her: Even heading out
into the world and feigning distress, to lure
people back into her terrible clutches.
That’s how the old man became SCP-957-1.
He wasn’t the first, and wouldn’t be the
last.
With the old man now dead,
SCP-957 would de-manifest
and head off in search of a new victim, invading
their home and repeating the cycle once more
somewhere else.
The somewhat happy ending is that in one of
these cases, the SCP Foundation somehow got
wise to the baiting activities of SCP-957,
and they were able to contain the creature,
giving it the Keter object class for its frequent
attempts to either get out or lure in new
victims.
It’s never been actively hostile to Foundation
researchers and guards, just a little obtuse.
Despite the fact that it’s perfectly capable
of speaking fluent English, it prefers to
speak in an unknown, dead language for somewhat
mysterious reasons.
Very little is known about the origins or
true nature of SCP-957, but our one brief
glimpse into its interior life does little
to comfort us.
In 2008, the Foundation recorded 957 having
a conversation with an unseen individual in
its native tongue.
Foundation linguistic experts have been able
to partially crack the code on what was being
said that day.
957 asked the unseen figure how much longer
it would have to stay here.
The figure told it that it would need to wait
there for a while and that its disguise was
extremely convincing.
957 complained that being “here” was boring
and tiresome, but the unseen figure urged
957 to remain patient.
It said “We have to let them watch the few
so that the many can move freely.
We will be done with our research soon enough…”
Now go check out “SCP-1861 - The Crew of
the HMS Wintersheimer” and “SCP-5049 - The
Skin Salesman - Demon Dan's Discount Homunculus
Depot” for more of the most terrifying anomalous
beings out there!